et lors de ce procès très médiatique un
nom revient celui de chelsea manning est
actuellement en prison pour avoir refusé
de témoigner contre julian assange
cette lanceuse d'alert est une ancienne
militaire américaine transgenres et son
histoire est liée à l'origine même de la
sphère wikileaks cécile à chaumont en
2009 celle ci manning est encore bradley
manning un analyste pour l'armée
américaine en irak
il découvre une facette obscure des
activités américaines en territoire de
guerre et décide de la faire connaître
ces images par exemple de la prison
irakienne d'abou ghraib font le tour du
monde et pour cause les soldats
américains y torture et humilient leurs
détenus des mois durant
au total 750 mille documents
diplomatiques et militaires
confidentiels que le soldat manning
décide de transmettre au site wikileaks
cela ce passe en 2010 résultat trois ans
plus tard la justice américaine condamne
manning à 35 ans de prison pour
violation du droit militaire
le lendemain il déclare sa nature
transgenres et entament des démarches
pour devenir chelsea en mai 2010 est
celle ci m'anime retrouvent la liberté
au bout de seulement sept ans sur
décision de l'administration obama
elle vit de conférences se lance même en
politique dans le maryland en 2018
l'obtient la deuxième place à la
primaire démocrate pour les élections
sénatoriales
mais l'année suivante celle ci manning
et deux nouveaux arrêtés et emprisonnés
la cause son refus de témoigner contre
julian assange à huis clos et sans la
présence d'un avocat
depuis mars 2019 elle la lanceuse
d'alerté détenu dans une prison fédérale
de l'état de virginie